previously on the walking dead shut up
Carly huh I've heard enough out of you
now
what the [ __ ] the problem I don't know
much about you folks I can tell you sure
the sun's gonna come up too
like is that
what are we do give me the car care
I think we should look for your parents
really yeah you need to know if they're
okay well if they're not what happened
to them
I was the one giving the bandit supplies
what it's all my fault we gotta jump
what no way
you son of a parent's right here
[Music]
you
all the going breath I'm super excited I
just woke up and seems like updating and
I was I couldn't be it and yeah we're
staring at their chins let's go we
arrived at Savannah Buress I don't know
what I feel about it though doesn't look
like it
nope how the idea was get across the
ocean
episode four around every corner
yes shava oh [ __ ] he can't why because
we pushed him so I clam may I mr. clam I
miss ya girl are you doing
I got your walkie now that's right just
hold it
I'm sorry Akane I think it's better if I
have it just for a little while I'm
close to where my mom and dad are
I'm sorry class not now Clementine maybe
later okay okay good girl Clementine
hopefully his legs pretty bad I'm fine
you're not fine you need to rest he
needs to rest
shut up alright so how much farther
Kenny how much farther to the riverfront
there should be just a few more blocks
up ahead and there'll be boats there sue
is he'll better be there'll be boats
have to be have to be it's going to be
okay Kenny knows what he's doing how can
they just walk it like that and feeling
safe that can't be good
that can definitely not be good maybe
this city's not so dead after all
keep movin no one's ringing that Bell
it's automatic on a timer what kind of
church bell goes off at 20 past the hour
yeah he's right
Tom what's up there are you sure I don't
see anything that's because they were
[ __ ] it in well hey hey you up there
dammit I thought you said that thing
didn't work I thought Soto
but al-adel is this for me what is going
on here bros there's gonna be zombies
hell was that there's so much trying to
[ __ ] with us sounded more like a warning
ask Not For Whom the Bell Tolls
what do I'm yammering on about how about
you just say there are zombies and we
should get out of here he know it's not
like attend I know him they're attracted
by the Bell they should know that come
on rod nice shovel breath time area all
right I'm gonna be so [ __ ] pissed
acclimatize hold on Johnny don't you
dare die on me
don't die Kenny I'm gonna be pissed of
Kenna dies shut up I think I'm a little
too close don't you think
now you better help out you son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] BAM
don't wake them [ __ ] all of you hey
Shannon thanks bro on they're not even
fast move your asses river streets right
over here that's not all them is right
up ahead give me a [ __ ] break
wait he's coming
yeah we're helping SEC
[ __ ] panda so there's none who that
guy gotta go now come on Portia them
everything that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up Thank
You Kenny
what about shot ah you okay yeah you've
opened up your room you're bleeding
we've got to get him inside clean him up
alright Kenny how's that dork I'm
working on it I'm working on it we'll
work faster would you shut up those
things outside figure out where we went
you know they can smell blood I'll find
a way I want to talk to clay me first
Clemmy alright she's waiting for shy
people sauce come back here how are you
going to find us no I don't think they
thought don't don't worry climbing some
fares for I can still hear them out
there it sounds like they're getting
closer
don't worry climbing clash feel safer we
were inside the house ah well I want to
have a talk with the [ __ ] Ben how
about you save a little it says maybe
it's like silent able to have that key
in the house nope well I think they have
proper fences in these houses all right
let me try the window we will be able to
bust through that what [ __ ] you been
good how about next time you saved a
little girl about what happened back
there on the street I know I don't know
what happened I just froze up hasn't
that ever happened to you know what I'm
singing to you you put that girl in
danger again it won't be walkers you
have to worry
that's right I hear you that's it I'm
gonna go check things out all right all
right why don't we go over here we an
will be able to bust through that why
not no way we're gonna force that open
now without making a lot of noise at
least okay maybe one of the windows no
they're all boarded up to have a shovel
maybe we can dig up this little grave
thing since a bit insensitive Mike why
don't one get Danny away but the one not
done they wait on the one man went but
digging it up dick digging it up girls
he doesn't want to start digging I guess
that makes sense
we'll be able to do that what's this
looks like there's some kind of pet door
here I tried it already that's locked -
who the hell ever heard of a locked
doggie door
I have my neighborhood one just like
that it's it's radio-controlled dog
where's it uh the door only opens when
they yeah and they burn it with a collar
every day's a school day okay all right
so where's the dog yeah I know where the
dog is all right let's get this over
with
this is really bad don't look climbing
you don't need to say this
hey be careful digging up dead things
isn't what it used to be you know what I
mean yeah fine climbing you better step
aside girl climby you shouldn't see this
all right what the hell is that a rat Oh
stay away Klim go over and sit with
Kristin oh okay what I want to just do
what I say okay all right
oh god the smell I mean I guess you've
seen a lot of things anyway please don't
come alive so he's not coming I can't
get it off yeah I'm glad time it and see
that are you sure you're okay dude
alright let's just get in the house now
couldn't we use this i won
[ __ ] it I'm sorry klemming yeah yeah
good now
I hope so it's getting cold out here I
don't think that's the biggest problem
right now clinically but let's get
inside
Jania spits strike twice yes God Daniel
so why so what you see anything in there
Oh Clem you can go through is that it do
well oh they're coming cause they're no
bueno you're gonna do do it fast
okay you see if I can reach up in there
careful man
no I can Clemmie good who has got to do
let me try I think I can hahaha very
clear are you okay are you okay say
something
Clemmy clue I love you
good job plan a job clear yeah way to go
yes you really girl you did good
can we maybe have this conversation
inside my legs starting to hurt like
hell looks okay from here everybody in
so why was it a good idea to go there
all right what do we got inside here
potato chips that's a big house
pretty fancy smancy that's a dog in the
picture sorry sorry no it's okay I'm
good
feel better already just being off my
feet you don't really look that good I'm
in that oh the dog was scaring me I
thought it was it so when were you gonna
tell us about the radio tell you what
that it's working that there's someone
else on the other end of that thing you
didn't think that might've been worth
sharing with the rest of us
okay fine you kidding I only found out
yesterday so both of you were keeping it
from the rest of us
great what's the big hit about the damn
radio I'm more worried about whoever it
was out there ringing that Bell and
bringing the dead down on top of us it's
like they didn't want us to make it to
the river what makes you think it's not
the same person whoever was on the radio
was close enough to see us in the street
and we didn't see anyone else other than
the guy in the building because that
doesn't make a lick of sense why would
they bring out the dead like that and
then try to warn us about it how much
this right anything make anymore in case
you haven't noticed there's a lot of
twisted folks out there these days
at least the dead don't play games with
you I don't know who it was all I know
is they're no friend of ours damn right
I'm telling you they don't want us get
into the river maybe they want those
boats all to themselves
no we'll see about that I'm not going
back out there any time soon omid needs
to rest
she's right let's rest at all use a
little time to rest up and gather our
thoughts Kinney at least until those
walkers outside wander off and old meets
feeling better he best feel better quick
ain't gonna wait around here too long
I know Kenny I know
place seems secure at least I'll feel
better when we know that for sure we
need to check the whole house alright
fine
you and me you'll take the upstairs Lee
you got down here make sure you check
every door understand okay
Clemmy uh can I help what if there's
another locked door uh if you've been
helpful enough for one day kiddo why
don't you just see if Kristin owe me you
need anything okay okay I'm sorry
climbing side we got man stuff to do all
right why don't we get no food half of
all Verde
why do we got here dog food and we're
gonna eat that I'm not that hungry
besides I need to finish checking the
downstairs
all right seems seems good but me my dad
asked about I'll take this probably not
the best idea right now no one cares
about shock caste or shock man looks
expensive and heavy doubt any looters
would be able to hold that thing too far
I'm no dinner for us I guess gang I have
to comment about literally everything
all right I need to check this door
hello don't kill me
nothing hard in here except the toilet
monster yeah not exactly my style
all right check the other door Oh
something is happening ah box all clear
in here
just one more to check
okay let's shake the life story I guess
I want talk to clay my face holding up
okay
I hope this house is safe have you
checked all the rooms to make sure not
yet let me clean secure of it
it's just alright alright let's check
the final door see what we got in here
ah it's a broom what happened please
ain't got much we should be okay here
for a while at least until the quiets
down outside good thanks
you I got your guy back girl is he okay
yeah no but I'm really worried his leg
might have gotten infected don't suppose
you turned up any meds while you were
poking around not just dog food and
there's some whiskey in the back
I was just asking Clementine if she
knows who the man on her radio is it's
okay honey you can tell us yeah tell us
who is it
what does he want go ahead Claire it's
okay you're not in any trouble
that's right Glenn it's just a friend I
don't think he wants to hurt us what has
he been saying to you what have you been
saying to him I told him I was trying to
find my parents and that they were in
Savannah he really seems nice
I think he wants to help me find them
Clementine
honey trust me that's not what he wants
he uh got something up you need to get
up here now
oh it's Kenny oh no Kenny said he
thought he heard something up there went
to go look he's up there
I can't get him to come down stay here
alright Prez I'm gonna end this episode
here
I like afraid of you Josh subscribe to
go home today and I'll see you next
episode see you tomorrow
you